en un vídeo anterior aprendimos la
noción de orbital es decir que los
electrones no orbitan un núcleo de la
misma forma en la que un planeta orbita
una estrella para describir donde se
encuentra un electrón en un tiempo dado
tenemos que pensar en probabilidades es
decir donde es más probable que lo
encontremos y donde es menos probable un
orbital es una descripción de esta misma
idea donde es más o menos probable que
lo encontremos este diagrama nos muestra
los tipos de orbitales que podemos
encontrar en varios sub niveles
energéticos o sub capas que encontramos
en los diferentes niveles energéticos o
capas tenemos el subnivel s el sub nivel
p que tiene tres diferentes orbitales el
subnivel t que tiene uno dos tres cuatro
cinco diferentes orbitales
después tenemos el subnivel efe
ahora bien cada orbital puede contener 2
electrones
así que si pensamos en el sub nivel ese
puede contener hasta 2 electrones es un
nivel p puede contener hasta 6
electrones el subnivel t puede contener
hasta 10 electrones y el subnivel efe
puede contener hasta 14 electrones 2 por
orbital ahora el objetivo de este vídeo
es que pensemos en la configuración
electrónica de un determinado átomo y
para ayudarnos
vamos a traer nuestra tabla periódica
primero pensemos en la configuración
electrónica del elemento más simple es
decir estamos hablando del átomo neutro
de hidrógeno un átomo neutro de
hidrógeno tiene un número atómico de 1
lo que nos dice que tiene un protón y es
neutro lo que significa que tiene un
solo electrón entonces donde estará es
electrón
bueno estará en el nivel energético más
bajo y ese primer nivel tiene un solo
sub nivel y un orbital sólo tiene el
psuv nivel ese entonces el único
electrón de un átomo neutro de hidrógeno
debe ir en ese sub nivel podemos decir
que su configuración electrónica es 1 s
es decir en el primer nivel sólo tenemos
un sub nivel s allí tenemos un electrón
que pasa si pensamos en el helio bueno
en un átomo neutro de helio hay 2
electrones entonces en lugar de tener un
electrón en este primer nivel hay 2
electrones su configuración electrónica
será 1 s 2
qué pasa cuando vamos al litio un átomo
neutro de litio tendrá 3 electrones por
lo tanto los dos primeros pueden
quedarse en el primer nivel energético
entonces los dos primeros electrones se
quedarán en 1 s 2 y el tercer electrón
se irá al segundo nivel pero el subnivel
que se llenará primero será el subnivel
ese entonces llegará al segundo nivel
energético y empezará a llenar el
subnivel s así que podemos observarlo
tenemos 2 electrones en el primer nivel
y un electrón en el segundo y qué hay
del berilio bueno se va a ver como el
litio pero ahora tenemos 4 electrones
dos de ellos se quedarán en el primer
nivel 1 s 2 y los siguientes 2 llenarán
el subnivel s del segundo nivel
energético aunque parezca trabalenguas
s 2 podemos observar que tenemos 4
electrones en total en el caso de un
átomo neutro de berilio y el borbón el
boro es interesante ya que un átomo
neutro de boro tiene 5 electrones los
dos primeros llenaran el primer nivel 1
s 2 los siguientes 2 llenarán el primer
sub nivel del segundo nivel es decir 2s
2 y ahora empezaremos a llenar el
subnivel p como tenemos un electrón más
entonces tenemos 2 p 1 es decir tenemos
un electrón en estos orbitales p ahora
qué pasa con el carbono bueno se va a
ver muy similar al boro pero tenemos un
electrón más para trabajar ya que un
átomo neutro de carbono tiene 6
electrones así que el electrón extra una
vez más va a caer en el subnivel p del
segundo nivel porque así podemos
contener 6 electrones
es decir vamos a llenar el primer nivel
de energético con 2 electrones después
el subnivel 2s con 2 electrones y
después tendremos 2 electrones más en el
subnivel 2 p todos ellos en el segundo
el nivel energético ahora podemos
imaginar que cuando tenemos átomos más y
más grandes con más electrones
esto puede ser bastante complejo
entonces una notación que a menudo se
utiliza es la configuración de un gas
noble en lugar de decir muy bien este es
el carbono podemos decir que el carbono
tiene la configuración electrónica del
helio recuerda los gases nobles son los
elementos de este grupo 8 de nuestra
tabla periódica entonces tiene la
configuración electrónica del helio que
sabemos que es esta de aquí y además de
esa configuración todavía tenemos 2s 2 y
después 2
podemos tomar la configuración
electrónica del helio y la ponemos justo
aquí y así obtenemos exactamente lo que
escribimos en un inicio